vier jahren einmal studio bzw einmal
eventkonzept gegründet das sind 2
stündige malkurse sag ich mal so für
leute die nicht malen können und mit
unserem perfekte entwickeltes system
malen wir in zwei stunden mit unsere
gäste eine wild und alle gehen dann
wirklich und hat die nach hause und wir
haben hauptsächlich im event bereich
gearbeitet mit große gruppen und haben
teilweise mit bis zu 160 leute gemalt in
riesen räume und es war immer sehr sehr
sehr schön und hat uns zusätzlich zwei
ganz tolle kleine studios wo auch
jedermann vom konnte und jederzeit bei
uns meinte einmal in köln und dann vier
jahre später in zwei punkten eröffnet am
corona und sie mussten schließen
die miete lief weiter sie durften
wahrscheinlich auch nicht sofort wieder
öffnen jetzt sind sie am ende und haben
jetzt noch weitere probleme welche sind
das haben eigentlich sehr viele probleme
also wir haben jetzt einen laden
schließen müssen
in köln einfach unbedingt größer kann
halt nicht so viele leute rein und haben
wir diesen berufen
die notbremse ziehen und der vermieter
lässt uns einfach nicht aus genauso wie
die telekom kredite aufgenommen haben
werden müssen wir weiter zahlen was ja
im normalfall auch richtig ist aber wir
haben einfach das geld mit und um die
leute kommen einfach auch nicht weil sie
angst haben weil vielleicht auch angst
gemacht wird oder auch gar nicht klar
ist dass man solche events jetzt in
kleinen gruppen wieder machen darf also
es sind einfach so viele viele kleine
probleme und dann durfte auch für diese
erste hilfe nur für einladen beantragen
weil wir zusammen gehören also dann das
geld reicht hinten und vorn ich weiß
jetzt einfach ganz viel was dann
schlecht ist sie haben uns erzählt sie
habe etwa 40.000 euro schulden und
werden jetzt auch aus ihren verträgen
nicht rausgelassen da muss ich mal zum
anwalt übergehen tatsächlich geht es
hier um einen nachmieter sie haben sich
selbst darum gekümmert und haben diverse
vorschläge
gesammelt können also dem vermieter
nachmieter empfehlen telekom ist einfach
sie müssen weiterhin alles bezahlen wie
ist das wenn es wenn einem das wasser
bis zum hals steht kann mich dann aus
solchen verträgen raus oder sind
wirklich konzerne da knallhart also bei
den gewerbe mietverträgen erleben wir
leider dass die konzerne knallhart sind
wir haben ja meistens langfristige
verträge fünf jahren oder zehn jahre und
wir haben auch die nachhaftung das
bedeutet selbst wenn ich also einen
nachmieter finden
dann tritt er in den mietvertrag ein und
meistens bleibt sozusagen der vermieter
der dann früher kündigt als vertraglich
vereinbart bleibt sozusagen als bürge im
den vertragsverhältnis bestehen
das ist ein natürlich ein gewisses
risiko ist aber so zulässig weil man
solche dauer mietverträge sind im
gewerbemietrecht erlaubt und dann ist es
natürlich gut wenn man nach meter findet
der vermieter muss sich in aller regel
auf diesen nachmieter auch einlassen
weil er ja sozusagen den vermieter noch
als bürgen hat so dass da im grunde
genommen erst mal alles richtig gemacht
ist wenn man also ein nachmieter benennt
dann kann man den vermieter auch unter
druck setzen den vertrag zu verändern
wenn man aber diesen schritt noch nicht
gehen will kann man im moment bei fast
allen vermietern aber auch einen rabatt
bekommen der erleben dass er häufig in
gesprächen mit vermietern weil die
vermieter froh sind dass die vernünftige
mieter haben die auch kommunizieren und
das ein ganz wichtiger punkt bitte immer
auf den vermieter zu gehen nicht einfach
die miete nicht bezahlen und dann nicht
mehr ans telefon gehen das darf auf
keinen fall sein
das erhöht nämlich die kosten weil dann
wäre anwälte natürlich sofort mit
räumungsklagen kommen für die vermieter
wenn man aber mit dem vermieter spricht
und dem die situation schildert sind im
moment eigentlich fast alle vermieter
bereit auch da was zu machen genau so
ist es auch bei den anderen anbietern
auch bei der telekom da kann man mit
sicherheit auch vereinbarungen treffen
frau bald wien wie geht es ihnen denn
jetzt
sie wirken jetzt gefasst wie schauen sie
die zukunft also ich wir haben keinen
plan
wir müssen jetzt gucken auch in
frankfurt überhaupt dem zweiten laden
halten können aber das sieht auch sehr
schlecht aus
also unter unser traum ist
wahrscheinlich geplatzt
und wir müssen uns jetzt wie anders
keine ahnung wir haben keine ahnung
wir haben eigentlich immer noch kleine
hoffnungen die statistik ist auch wieder
verpuffen weil einfach dann doch keiner
kommt und keiner buch die neuen kroner
zahlen lassen wir auch nicht unbedingt
hoffnung zu ja also ja ich möchte gerne
mal zu den vermieter zurück wir hatten
das auch alles gemacht mit dem
vermietern ab also wir hatten ihn
gefragt aber der hat gar nicht mehr geht
das war nämlich unbedingt als er auf und
stärkt also die ersten antworten kam
zwei monate später und dann ist es auch
nie ist jetzt nicht mehr so schlimm
funktioniert nicht brauchen nicht
weniger stunden oder was auch immer
aber also deswegen hier wissen gar nicht
wie es weitergeht dass man weil man nur
absolut ihren hier stößt und man hat ihr
haben das wissen riesenangst jetzt mit
diesen schulden da rauszugehen im job zu
finden weiß es ist auch nicht die beste
zeit also sich wieder anstellen lassen
als was würden sie arbeiten deswegen
müssen erst gucken was wir müssen erst
die keine ahnung also ich habe immer was
kreatives gemacht und künstlerischen
bereich also und beides schiene talente
und aber wir haben jetzt hier so viel
energie investiert ich weiß nicht ob wir
jetzt was wo oder wann wir hoffen am
ende ja es ist einfach man steht fürs
auf und muss auch was man nicht einfach
liegen bleibt weil weil man gar nicht
weiß was ist das etwas was soll das das
casino freut ist dass er alles für wir
haben so gekämpft gleich von anfang an
für pakete und für alles mögliche
versuchen mit jedem gesprochen und neue
sachen entwickelt und wenn das alles
nichts bringt die luft ist einfach raus
und fünf monate so machen einfach müde
ohne dass irgendwas zu kommen wir können
auch jetzt nicht dass das verflixte ist
man jetzt auch
kein geld ausgeben zu werbung um
vielleicht schon jetzt zu werben oder
den zusagen davon hier malen und kleine
gruppen wurde das vier bis zwölf leute
jetzt sind wir haben einfach nicht mehr
das geld um irgendwelche werbung zu
schalten also ist willkommen einfach
nicht aus diesem loch heraus
ja das ist wirklich eine ganz ganz
bittere situation trotzdem sage ich
ihnen toll dass sie auch in dieser
sendung waren auch den mut gefunden
haben darüber zu sprechen
ich wünsche ihnen alles gute vielleicht
geht es irgendwann weiter ich drücke
ihnen jedenfalls beide da